welcome Martin Freeman is here you see
how's it going good to see you yeah
we're sit down that works yeah yeah you
come right in and and we're good to go
welcome man how are you I'm very well
thanks yeah
very good you look uh you look thinner
it was that day you trying to lose you
look good do I look for now yeah yeah
since the last time I saw you when was
that
probably about three years ago uh maybe
yeah maybe I think it goes up that
literary depending on the pie situation
at any given time okay if there's a pie
available if it's a pave I will probably
eat that so if you go through like a six
month string of like a lot of places
that have pie I'll make it on a couple
pounds then uh could be as big as a
house right yeah but over the last
couple years there hasn't been that many
pies no ouch what I mean I'd in all
honesty I try and be vaguely sensible
without being obsessive yeah yeah yeah I
try not to make it the focus of my life
because I love food mm-hmm but then I
you know when I hit 40 I kind of thought
well it's this is only gonna go
potentially downhill right right so I
thought well I better sort of start
looking after myself you catch yourself
looking in the mirror and like ah my fat
roll is hanging over do I get those
horrible my woods never have anything
like that because I've got well I've got
a perfect body so no I I look at myself
I go why was nine 300 that's my main
right that's my main University yeah I
literally will sit doing this show will
be in the middle of an interview and
I'll catch Jim out of the corner of my
eye as I'm asking a question just
completely lose focus look down at his
gut and just make a face and I'm like
what are you doing jumping when you're
sitting it it's just there and it just
hangs over just relax right but anything
sometimes it comes as a surprise your
middle your middle comes up right
because you think you can think I'm
doing fine with my middle it's fine all
right you put a certain thing on or you
put a certain jump of it's a bit of
sweater that's a bit too thick or
something right and also you eat pies
any you think I'm not doing that well
right yeah like you put on a t-shirt
that's a little too clingy in your leg I
didn't realize that grown breasts that
I've done things where I you know um I'm
camera unfortunately my work life is on
camera friend and sometimes you've worn
something that I look fine in this and
see it back and go why did no one tell
me
why didn't anyone tell me there's no one
on the sets gonna tell you like you look
good yeah they should don't don't bother
him don't bother it you're like oh
please please bother me yeah and there's
got to be a way for them to say it
without being insulting like we don't
know I think there is I think that given
that I'm a reasonably approachable
person you someone could probably say
I'm telling you now that's not the most
flattering thing you've ever worn and I
would probably pick up that code you
take it's a pretty yeah that's not very
flattering it's like you're gonna blow
your brains out when you see yourself
maybe go layers today because everything
is that everything is touching in the
wrong spot
yeah man do you watch do you watch your
stuff back like do I only watch my stuff
yeah this is my DVD collection
anyway you want to say yeah yes I will
always see something at least once
yeah if I if if I don't like it it will
only be once but I just think everything
is kind of instructive what if you like
that you've done because you've done I'd
say more than most actors you've done a
lot of projects that people become super
fans of whether it's you know like
Sherlock people are super fans are you
know the office obviously Fargo Lord of
the Rings like everything people develop
these like fascinations with these
projects like what do you like that
you've done well I like all of those
things you know man I really like it and
I like a lot of things that other people
haven't seen you know I've been you know
as I'm sure we all have you know we've
done work with it I'm really proud of
that and no one else cares about it will
knows about it right I've done things
like that that 20 people have seen but
of the famous stuff I like all that you
know I mean it's a sort I suppose the
office is when I became known ray and
that was very up my street yeah that's
like who am i yeah it was just
completely my taste
yeah well I loved it I loved doing it
and it was a joy every day to do you
know and they're all original feeling
like the original office changed I mean
that was the first to do it that way
with with you know like the mock
documentary yeah and and Sherlock is so
originally shot yeah eautifully show
really is this one does web so you're
blogging I think was in season two yeah
and like the words are just showing up
on the screen it was just such an
original way to to
well I mean I think the the visual
vocabulary of the show of Sherlock was
kind of started largely by the first
director a Scottish guy called Paul
McGuigan it's what paralyzed well he's a
kind of visual genius really and I think
that decision to just not cut away to a
phone when there's a text or not cut
away to a screen when there's an email
but just have it on on screen as obvious
you know I've seen that sense you know
and it's and it's that's been pretty
influential and yeah so once it happens
you think you have caught of course why
don't we just do that like we'll buy
that in a screen you know it feels
updated it feels more current than
seeing something going right to it
because it's it's not it's now it's like
when I see things cut away to a script
and of course you can still do that well
and things things that are good might
still do that but it suddenly looks a
bit clunky now it does and I mean like
visually it makes more sense right
because like when we look at a screen we
generally still have peripheral issue
yeah so we're kind of aware of what's
going on oh yeah and it's just I think
it's just a nice little is a nice
aesthetic yeah just a stylistic thing I
think it's really it's really good just
to kind of just to do something to an
audience subconsciously that goes all I
haven't seen that
do you like stuff like that because I
would assume you don't know unless if I
guess it's described in the scrim but I
would assume you don't know that's gonna
happen until not the first time I think
now it tends to get written in it's it's
sort of assumed now that when that when
there is text you know when characters
text or email each other it's assumed
that we will see it on screen like that
but the first time you got I go that's a
call choice yeah yeah but like the first
time it happened it's like oh well that
was a complete surprise to all of us
yeah it's one of those things that we
get so used to here in the click of the
keyboard and then I went like watching
the guy sound out what he's saying as oh
yeah like the worst one people type is
terrible I know I know but also I feel
like being you know being an actor in
this century so much of you know you did
a lot of scenes with technology more
than I want to actually you did love
think of it I just want to do 12 Angry
Men I just want to sit around a table
and argue and drink coffee that if I
could do that that's for me the
blueprint of all great enjoyment as an
actor yeah just talk and shout at people
did you originally you saw the original
road yeah that's the best yeah I mean
just but it's certainly that it's a
great film but just that idea of just
human beings you know doing things to
each other in a space
not in that way I can even why don't I
know how to that as well as on the film
emotional and psychological things to
each other without without a screen in
sight I think would be marvelous what
did you do before you a kit very little
actually yeah very little I kind of I
knew I wanted to be an active from about
1718 so I never had a proper proper job
young man I'll never had like another
trade wow that's amazing they don't yes
very few people that really who weren't
child actors who just start out kind of
in young adulthood and just make a
career out of it that's amazing okay
right no I know I've certainly been very
lucky for you Mike um okay thank you see
I'm not very tech know when a believe me
for us I know we have I been she's been
a personal conversation yes we're not
even on yet welcome back okay so time
this is for the public um no I I thought
but I didn't go to drama school till I
was like 21 so I was out in the world
working at 23 yeah so kind of young age
but not not that young why do you want
to be an actor like I mean obviously we
love doing it but did you just see
somebody go that's what I want to do or
what made you want to do it um probably
a mixture of a mix obviously I guess a
mixture of seeing movies and the odd
play and just seeing drama and seeing
comedy that I loved but also I joined a
Youth Theatre I think I had this idea as
a 15 year old as a little lefty 15 year
old that somehow
theatre was going to be kind of a
political act you know I did sort of I
had that idea as well yeah we'll be able
to when they get different yeah yeah
yeah I guess yeah I did you know however
um naive that it was I think I probably
thought it was so no when did you get to
the point where you were like why not
[ __ ] acting is just acting and I have to
be okay with that I'm not yeah um well
quite early on yeah I think quite early
on because uh because although I think
it can not acting itself but acting as
part of the storytelling process I think
can make little differences you know I
think we just as the mood music of our
culture music cinema plays books are
they do make a difference definitely but
if they may
it made that much of a difference they'd
ban it as the old saying if it was that
effective make it is there anything you
want to address in acting that you
haven't been able to yet like is there
anything you like I would love to kind
of take this on Monica Liz I have to say
I'm kind of I'm in a place at the moment
where I am very happy with where things
are going as far as I think in the wake
of the office I think people that either
just I mean a lot of people thought I
was a stand-up but a lot of people
diverse you assumed that I was from that
background cuz at that time in the UK I
was doing lots of comedy bits and I was
Ernie was not a stand-up but uh so then
it was my goal to kind of want to kind
of do straighter things a little bit
more dramatic things and I've kind of
feel I've you know I'm doing that yeah
the United you're not looked at as it go
he's a comic actor certainly not all
right you know most of the time I mean
so for people under under 30
I mean people never talk to me about the
office right that it's it's not really a
thing isn't that amazing it kind of is
efficient from where you were yeah great
every when I was 30 yeah that's all
people were talking to me about and
thank God for it you know I was very
proud of it but um know that it doesn't
really figure for people who who've sort
of gotten into the things that I do in
the last sort of five six years it holds
up though I watched with somebody who
had never seen the original she was big
on the American and it which was good I
guess but I I live in Madison so we
watch this the series finale last night
fun okay so good I mean it's just it's
it's it's I think it's the best like
sitcom quote-unquote that's ever been
done because so perfectly acted and
everybody that's believable yeah and
flawed in the clothes were imperfect
yeah there's a bunch of really beautiful
people in perfect clothes like mostly
humor is like understated and real you
know what I mean yeah well I'm glad you
like I I still think it's really good
you know if ever I catch it now if it's
on I think but no that dust really hold
up yeah I was you know because that for
Ricky and Stephen and where I sort of
bonded with them was it was like it was
the Simpsons Laurel and Hardy and spinal
tap that was the things that I remember
we were always talking about you know
and then so I get and I guess that show
has little snippets of all those things
you know but surly spinal tap as the the
the truly first and still I think best
executed
mock dock thing is a huge influence on
anything that comes in that in that vein
since then because again there are very
few times in spinal tap where you think
are there this is a joke joke you know
the my favorite bits of spinal tap but
the bits just the throwaway bits the
bits that aren't you know it's not all
the these go up to 11 and stone Angeles
even though there's our fantastic yeah
it's this the little bits that people
are just again just things that
characters are doing to each other
non-verbally a lot of the time I think
it's just true true genius did you just
write did you audition for the office
was it just I did yeah I did it was it
was I auditioned Ricky wasn't it was the
merger was in the room with Asha Tala
their producer I had worked with Ricky
on a sketch show earlier that year
excuse me he had he had written a few
sketches for a sketch show that I did
with the team of you know very good you
know I was young I was like 27 veloute
very good so young British comedy people
and and Ricky's material was just
obviously really fun it was genuinely
funny you know in an in a slightly
off-kilter away and so when I saw that
he and Stephen had written the script I
was sent up for the audition and an
illiterate for Gareth the part of Gareth
ah who Mackenzie Crook played and and
that went however it went and I was on
my way out literally and and Stephen
said I think maybe you should read for
Tim and it was like one of those showbiz
moans like I was nearly out the door
yeah I wouldn't have got it because
Mackenzie was great as Gareth and that
was out what that was supposed to be so
I came back and read his team and it was
just much more natural as his then a bit
footage of you reading is uh again yeah
is there footage of that was I'm not
sure it might be I mean this was late 99
so I'm not sure what I mean I wasn't
doing what Mackenzie I wasn't doing that
accent and I wasn't you know observe and
everything is a pretty specific thing I
don't know what I would have done as
Gareth but you know Gareth is now that's
Mackenzie what he does is great and yeah
clearly what I did is Tim was just more
natural fit for me but sometimes you see
these audition tapes of people who are
running for roles you know you know John
Goodman is a godfather yeah I love that
Godfather stuff I know all the people
you sort of see reading for Coppola in
the early seventies think
that would have been a different film
yeah who I mean DeNiro read for the
first one I think and I Michael I think
we're sunny nothing and you see once in
a while a few people that read it's
always interesting to see somebody
reading for something I love see Martin
Sheen Martin Sheen read for The
Godfather as well and I think he might
have read for Michael
well Robert Redford read I believe
Robert Redford was touted around
originally for Michael Corleone all
right thank you yeah but a couple
Coppola obviously went nah he's great
and he's loved but he doesn't really
look very Sicilian yeah yeah I love all
that I love it because it again if those
people had got the parts you think well
it might still have been a it might be
when people say I never trust when
people say you were the only person who
gonna play well of course you're not of
course you're not 15 other people kind
of play the edges would have been
different and it might have been better
in my been worse but there's always more
than you in line for a part well there's
footage to I they'd started shooting
Apocalypse Now with Harvey Keitel in my
scenes role and I would love to see that
footage I don't know if he got fired or
if they didn't agree on what I'm not
sure why it happened but I know that
there was like a long long shoot well
then they did like half of back to the
future with Eric Staal right like almost
a full half of the movie how about very
recently yeah never knew that yes and
then every that reason there is footage
of that though you can see I meant to it
on the DVD eventually but then yeah then
they had to bring in Michael J Fox and
reshoot the entire half of the movie
that they already shot what happens when
you're not when something's not working
and they have to tell you like that's
gonna be humiliating I would be really
hard I think it would be really really
obvious he's never happened to me
because I am a well not flawless actor
but I'm you know getting on for that
yeah I don't know and I've asked myself
that like what would that would be a
very very tough call not just for you to
hear it but right how do you tell
someone if you're a nice human being how
do you say sorry we're gonna go in
another direction you tell the agent
they tell the agent date and here by the
way and then it goes on to be a massive
hit yeah cuz Michael J Fox was so great
then you're like you can't even deny
that they made the right call Yeah right
yeah right unless you're just trying to
say like one I think just the whole
movie was a big hit I would have been
just yeah it would have been a hit
regard though that's true is because
obviously Michael J Fox was fantastic in
that he was already was already
fantastic on TV but you know I'm sure
Eric Stoltz would've been really good
and then film would have it because the
film's a good idea is well directed and
Christopher Lloyd's
great so everything's good move yeah
yeah instead of what yeah just on what
level I know you know but I want to see
more I want to see Harvey Keitel you
know do it doing more I can't picture
Vietnam [ __ ] I can't I really really
want to see that you should see his type
of Sherlock that was it say yeah put
your pants on I can't be naked myself oh
by the way America come about just so
great
I surely such it is hard to be so unique
with a role that has been done by a lot
of different people over the years yeah
and I you really you guys pulled it off
no he's definitely brought something
else in like say you know over a century
old that part and and there have been so
many incarnations of it but Benedict has
something special about his incarnation
without question yeah yeah would you I
guess you could ask the same question
about The Hobbit series but I we had
Billy Bob Thornton in here a couple
weeks ago
and the question I asked him about Fargo
which is the same one for you is when
you sign up to do that show how do you
what was that noise that's my drilling
I'm doing it someone's falling I don't
know what a drill I was like wait oh wow
oh they're doing stuff outside my guess
it picked up in here why would you equip
the radio studio to be a Foley sound /
oh yeah what was that oh no somebody
dropped a ring outside cook um yeah how
do you know when you sign up to do a
show like that that it's going to be
what it was which is an original work
and not kind of a rehash of this movie
that everybody loves you know what I
mean because it's a risk it's a very big
risk in this show could have gone you
know it could have been awful especially
for your character specifically because
that's so obviously like the essence is
inspired by wait a minute yeah yeah yeah
well I mean from my purpose I read the
first episode and and there were I mean
particularly there's a scene in the
first episode of Fargo between my
character and Billy's character in a
hospital where he kind of basically does
a kind of mind trick on me and sort of
it with his charisma lures me into the
possibility of you know killing people
and that was so brilliantly written her
and so compellingly written I thought I
have
I have to do this you know as for the
bill Macy thing um I can honestly sign
and it won't surprise you I didn't go
near it I got and I had still haven't
seen the entire film since 1998 or
whatever you know yeah cuz I saw there's
no way I'm gonna go oh what can I pick
that's disastrous it is a quarter they
offer you this point you have to read
for it they write for that I did not
have to read watch again was kind of
amazing because again that accents
pretty specific yeah and that could have
been awful yeah been horrendous a
horrendous mistake but you have to be
very proud of that because that I mean
obviously you know there was an
award-winning show that was a great
performance thank you thank you no I
don't know I'm very pleased with that
I'm not but at the same time I I didn't
have a single bad day on it the whole
show was you know Noah Hawley is a great
writer he had a great vision for that
show I think to make it yes to kind of
have a nod toward the Coen brothers
without sort of slavish Lee aping them
but just to for being its own show right
and Billy's amazing galas and Tolman's
amazing you know Bob Odenkirk but you
know everyone was fantastic in it Colin
Hanks it was it was full of quality and
you also sorry you also give the the
casting director a lot of credit yeah
like like - like we need somebody from
what Minnesota or Fargo North Dakota
that accent who should we get ah Martin
Freeman he's like what a genius casting
director to look at you and go this is
the guy for that well it felt brilliant
it's always very nice to feel trusted
you know because if you think that
people are trusting you with things that
are slightly outside of what they seen
you do that's a big vote of confidence
had you done American accents before on
I felt I had but not not many and I've
done a few since then but um but but not
that specific thing you know yeah that's
not just like oh it's you know none of
you guys sound like that you know it's
it's a very specific thing is it easy to
do an American accent because British
actors pull it off so well in so many
shows and it just seems to me like
you'll be very hard to do if you didn't
because I don't really recognize
differences in British accents yeah well
I mean that know there are cuz they're a
massive massive differences I think
maybe you don't hear you know you might
not hear Geordi or Scouts or mank very
often you know but that they are there
or even I think people even here have a
difference I have a hard time between
Scots and Irish you know which to us is
there's a very clear difference yeah
I think it helps that we grew up with
jazz rock and roll and Hollywood
gentleman so that shows that those
things are sort of intravenously put
into you from a very early age so that
you you know we all know the difference
between you know Tony Soprano and you
know whoever you know country music
whatever yeah you know so those accents
are kind of in your map somewhere we you
know we wouldn't be we'd need to learn
about the specifics of them and
obviously I need to work my ass off to
get that tend to get less than I guards
accent but but still yeah you have a
general thing you know whereas I think
in America in a way you probably hear a
very very limited amount of English
accents right and it's just British like
well yeah generation brass of course
Brit British is for country right as
Northern Ireland Wales Scotland and
England that's a whole country and
within those places there's loads of
accent where did where did you get the
Lester's accent from if you if it wasn't
because obviously you're not just gonna
pull the accent from the movie as you
know said so like did you have to find
any other people so I thought I had a
voice coach for about four maybe three
or four Skype sessions and then I had
there's a guy there was a guy on set all
the time who took kind of fun for
everyone cuz not many people were from
Minnesota all right job you know so he
was he was there kind of helping us all
on the day with her a moment where he
went although you got to redo that that
that didn't come out proper no because
by the time uh no never that but but for
instance if I'd be reading it with him
he said let me just hear you read that
line and I'd read it and he would amend
maybe a bit pronunciation there so by
the time you get in front of camera you
know you know that you shouldn't be
having to do it again because of accent
but I would like if I had a week off for
two weeks off excuse me I would just
pull up things on YouTube just real
Minnesotans talking right I would pick
up that just you just want you to look
at Minnesota person time you can when
you do Minnesotan accent I mean the
trouble is very often you know people do
people use those accent things as a way
of kind of showing off their broad array
of accents but when you hear the real
deal um yeah that just keyed me back
into it you know because some of those
vowel sounds are sources for a foreigner
they're pretty surprising what a
surprising vowel sound I had
a I had a line in it that was something
like I have I think the line was I have
to drink it through a straw that was
that that was there so I think I said
yeah I had to drink it through a straw
and he end the gut and the accent coach
said no it's it straw I was like
strapped Ria's like STR aw end up saying
strap and I thought that can't be right
but it was right you know some of it is
more extreme than you would think and
some of it is less extreme unit thing I
think on that show we were trying not to
make it cartoony and try to respect the
people actually lived in Minnesota
rather than make them all over the back
of an SNL skit right I think my favorite
part of that show is the development of
the characters because like that my fate
I keep coming back to the scene at the
end of that season in the elevator yeah
yeah
when because you have like this ego
about you shouldn't have and like it's
this instant where you get reminded
absolutely that no matter what you're
exactly you're both exactly who you were
you and Billy Bob are exactly who you
were yes when the show started yes it's
brilliant yeah it was brilliant
you know I don't mean what we did was
brilliant but all of you know it Billy
was bloody marvelous but um but the
right it's just so good it's really
well-written so every every episode that
you read you just go wow I get to do
that oh I get to do that do you do you
turn stuff down or are you just like
yeah I'm an actor I'm a working actor
because a lot of actors and when you ask
him like oh you know how do you make
your choices they'll tell you well they
offer me and then I go okay I'll do it
whatever whatever the job is okay I do
to me I don't turn things down yeah I do
because I've always believed in them if
you get like if you've got seven kids to
feed and you need to make the rent then
all letter off sure will you get that
and if you just like being out of a
house all the live long back fine but um
no I've always believed in my taste like
I've always believed that should play a
part of it do your kid I do seven I've
got a feet I have two kids you know but
but I think once once you've made the
rent and I think once you can feed
people then it I think will choo-choo
my feeling for me is I would not forgive
myself if I didn't feel I was trying to
choose wise and one would hope right
that if you start choosy then people
will start associating
you with those projects that you
consider are good this is nice right
yeah of course
yeah of course yeah I mean you need the
luck in the first place yeah but I think
why not help make your own luck by by
exercising your taste yeah everyone says
there's an actor's the only power you've
got is to say no so I say no a lot I
believe in that yeah when you refer but
the office was first aired in in Britain
didn't it not do as well as it
eventually did like the first that they
didn't take to it at first so we like oh
god this is the bust no I never thought
it's a bust because again that was my
biggest part on TV so far so either way
for what I listen if some people like it
that's great and I knew it had a small
core of followers but yeah the first
time it went out it went out like in the
summer like summer BBC two nine o'clock
no stars in it you know so it's all
pretty unknown cars and some people the
ultimate accolade for me is it genuinely
some people read it and occasionally
even reviewed it like it was a real
documentary and that's great perfect
yeah accolade you know because they
believe we we were real people
they then riche owed it I think about
four or five months later and then it it
really really did very well I mean I
think yeah when it went out it I knew
that there were hardcore fans who loved
it in that tapi way that spinal tap II
where like this is there's something
detailed here and there's something
going on but it got very very popular
sort of year half a year later where it
was it was a big deal and I would
imagine when you're picking projects
like part of that is that right when
that does become a big deal everybody
wants to go from the office to be like
they just take that character and put it
into their project and probably the same
thing with a lot of the stuff that
you've done absolutely I mean Pete yeah
and that's what you have to try and
avoid against and try and kind of accept
it to a certain degree accept that
that's the reality of it of course but
to try and just manipulate it so that
you can go okay I know you want me to do
that but I also want to do this and when
you hear about Ricky's doing life on the
road yes the David Brent did you were
you approached to be an arrow did you
not well no not know I wasn't approached
I mean I've seen it and it makes me
laugh because I think that character is
a very very funny character and it's
brilliantly executed but no no no one
else I think was I think yeah that was
just his own thing there was totally
separate friendly separate yeah but just
that character doing is there a part of
you that goes like
I wish I wish I could have brought back
my character as well and done something
with this or you kind of notice they
never say never ever no never because I
believe in the finite nature of things
you know yeah and I like things being
left alone you know I've never been a
massive fan of reunions I've never been
a massive fan of yeah just what again
when I was a kid don't tell that to the
girls from four house that were just in
yeah they have they live for you
surprise mark our unions can be great
yeah I'm sure
listen if Ricky and Steve wrote a
phenomenal episode of The Office right
then I would have to obviously consider
that very seriously sure but when I was
a kid reunions were seen as kind of
tacky you know like bands reuniting was
kind of they didn't do it you know um
and now it's absolutely part of our
cultural life that everyone writes five
minutes we've now got to get together
again and you know is that right the
bank account we cashed in on something
like that's it let's milk it we gotta
milk it till it's dry while you're
milking it unquestionably a massive
financial aspect to that you also have
to pretend that you're doing it for
great artistic and confidence as well
and sometimes you might be there you
know you might be but um I don't know I
like things I don't I don't think we're
going to make an episode better than we
made fourteen fifteen years ago how long
do you think you're going to do Sherlock
for because Sherlock season four series
four I guess it is premieres January 1st
at 9 p.m. on PBS it sure does
four is a lot for you for the series
that you've done like you're either two
star one season when I first season of
our series of a didn't a well how many
episodes were in the first series of
sure only three only three and all of
them uh I didn't part uh I'm corrective
didn't part didn't the third series have
seven no no there's three is literally
been four seasons of three episodes and
one special we're way over last year
called the abominable bride yeah that
was all--no they've only been three but
they're all an hour and a half you know
it's like we're giving you three little
movies right you know it's not that
stingy right right do you have any idea
how long you want this to run on for
just until it's not I think I just think
until it's a natural port I think life
does sometimes have a way of telling you
yeah oh this is this is probably it now
I mean it does it does feel you know
this love
Cirie's did have a feeling of other
whether its finality to it but it
certainly had a feeling of a pause to
write it definitely had a feeling of
that and I I'm never ever afraid of
things ending you know I I like I don't
mean you know I'm not looking forward to
life ending love ending order but but
things that we make
I think should end you really do have a
very good grasp on finite things like
because you you do leave people wanting
more like that you guys easily could
have been in in another season of Fargo
people would have enjoyed seeing or
something every Walker thing yeah they
did not six six and then a two-part
series is like yeah yeah I know I was
fast but can you imagine though that the
alternative is and we all know the
alternative is that you know you leave
people wanting less and people saying I
wish you'd stop five years ago that's a
that's not a good place to be however
much money you've made I mean at my
entire career okay I know I want less
from you just from this right the great
news is going to say for everybody is
this is the ending of this interview
it's over now I've really enjoyed that
was way yes I'd like Sam said series for
Sunday January first nine o'clock on PBS
yeah made great also great and Martin
it's been it's been great talking about
I've already enjoyed it thank you